Frankie Rhoden saying if you were able
to choose the sex of your offspring
would you we've talked before about
whether this is going to be something
that is readily available to parents at
some point in the future I think just to
get it out of the way that it absolutely
will be readily available and sort of
relatively affordable I don't know
exactly when it will be how affordable
but I think that this within I don't
know some reasonable number of years is
going to be pretty pretty affordable
what do you think about that just on the
science of it affordability I think it
would be relatively affordable I mean it
as it's available to the general public
I think so ok so I think we have no
disagreement about whether the
technology will allow for this given
that would we want to choose the sex of
offspring I'm sort of leaning towards as
someone who doesn't have kids I'm
leaning towards no if I were to have a
kid as former producer Lewis once said
if I accidentally had a kid I'd probably
love the kid if I deliberately had a kid
I'd probably love the kid
that's not really at issue and I think
that gender would play no role in that
however I do have friends who continued
having children because they had one
girl two girls they were hoping to have
a boy and just kind of be done with it
because they wanted kids of both sexes
they had a third girl and thus they
continued having kids beyond when they
otherwise might have because they were
seeking that illusive boy I think in
those situations maybe it's perfectly
reasonable to choose the sex of your
offspring and from a population control
aspect you want to boy a girl you have a
girl you get pregnant you choose a boy
you're now done and you have two kids
that you're bringing into the world
rather than maybe having to have three
four or five kids before you get that
boy and then you have to claim
afterwards that you love all the kids
equally so Corinne I kind of have the
same answer where I wouldn't want to
choose the sex of the child for the
first child but maybe if I had a boy the
first time around I would want to have a
girl afterward right but you start to
get into this slippery slope because if
you can choose the sex of the baby our
other thing is kind of up for grabs like
can you choose the height
or you know I color some of these other
things they're just physical attributes
well very often when we have this
conversation at some point the idea of
something that feels like eugenics gets
brought up which is okay well listen
you're gonna have to sex and if you
could also a quote fix or modify certain
genetic predisposition to diseases what
about physical attributes what about eye
color what about intelligence trait
predisposition how far are you going to
go and we actually interviewed NYU
professor and New York Times ethicists
Arthur Caplan about this issue and he
had a pretty specific way which is
you're allowed to modify traits
depending on whether or not they'd be
passed down genetically to the next
offspring generation and that that would
be a way to think about what types of
genetic modifications could be made
ethically in his view or not so there
are sort of objective ways where we
could prevent such a slippery slope so
what does I mean like you you can't be
superhuman in any way but if the genes
kind of already exist in the parents
then you can select which ones get
passed down to the next generation yes
more or less more alike that's the idea
so I think that that's a problem that
could be solved but if I were able to
choose the sex of my offspring would I
probably not except in the situation I
mentioned where if I had some now you
could also argue why why would why our
parents so determined to have children
of a certain sex and is that even a
legitimate desire many people would say
yes some people would say no I think
it's just the idea of the typical
American family where they have a mom
and a dad a boy and a girl and maybe a
third of a dog right yeah I recent
someone recently wrote something saying
they have three point five kids and I
had no clue what that meant and I think
maybe the point five refers to a dog do
some that has some people I don't know I
was just thinking of the nuclear family
and how I think of whether average yeah
now I know you mean okay that's my view
on that